The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
GILBERT STRANG: OK, let
me start one minute early.
So this being MIT, I just came
from a terrific faculty member,
Andy Lo in the Sloan
School, and I have
to tell you what he told us.
And then I had to leave before
he could explain why it's true,
but this is like an amazing fact
which I don't want to forget,
so here you go.
Everything will
be on that board.
So it's an observation about us
or other people, maybe not us.
So suppose you
have a biased coin.
Maybe the people playing
this game don't know,
but it's 75% likely
to produce heads,
25% likely to produce tails.
And then the player has
to guess for one flip
after another heads or tails,
and you get $1 if you're right,
you pay $1 if you're wrong.
So you just want to get
as many right choices
as possible from this
coin flip that continues.
So what should you do?
Well what I hope we
would do is we would not
know what the probabilities
were, so we would guess maybe
heads the first time,
tails the second time,
heads the third time, and so on.
But the actual result
would be mostly heads,
so we would learn at some point
that-- maybe not quite as soon
as that.
We would eventually
learn that we should
keep guessing heads, right?
And that would be
our optimal strategy,
to guess heads all the time.
But what do people actually do?
They start like
this, the same way,
and then they're
beginning to learn
that heads is more common.
So maybe they do more
heads than tails,
but sometimes tails is right,
and then after a little while,
they maybe see that it's-- yeah.
Well maybe they're not
counting, they're just
operating like ordinary people.
And what do ordinary people
actually do in the long run?
You would think guess
heads every time, right?
But they don't.
In the long run, people
and maybe animals
and whatever guess heads three
quarters of the time and tails
one quarter of the time.
Isn't that unbelievable?
They're guessing tails
a quarter of the time
when the odds are
never changing.
Anyway, that's something that
economists and other people
have to explain, and if I had
been able to stay another hour,
I could tell you
about the explanation.
Oh, I see I've written
that on a board
that I have no way to bury,
so it's going to be there,
and it's not the
subject of 18.065
but it's kind of amazing.
All right, so there's good
math problems everywhere.
OK.
Can I just leave you with what
I know, and if I learn more,
I'll come back to that question.
OK.
Please turn attention
this way, right?
Norms.
A few words on norms,
like that should
be a word in your language.
And so you should
know what it means
and you should know a few
of the important norms.
Again, a norm is
a way to measure
the size of a vector or the
size of a matrix or the size
of a tensor, whatever we have.
Or a function.
Very important.
A norm would be a
function like sine x.
From 0 to pi, what would be
the size of that function?
Well if it was 2 sine x, the
size would be twice as much,
so the norm should reflect that.
So yesterday, or Wednesday,
I told you that--
so p equals 2, 1,
actually infinity,
and then I'm going to put in
the 0 norm with a question mark
because you'll see
that it has a problem.
But let me just
recall from last time.
So p equal to 2 is the usual
sum of squares square root.
Usual length of a vector.
p equal 1 is this
very important norm,
so I would call
that the l1 norm,
and we'll see a lot of that.
I mentioned that it plays
a very significant part now
in compressed sensing.
It really was a bombshell in
signal processing to discover--
and in other fields,
too-- to discover
that some things really
work best in the l1 norm.
The maximum norm has a
natural part to play,
and we'll see that,
or its matrix analog.
So I didn't mention the l0 norm.
All this lp business.
So the lp norm, for any p,
is you take the pth power--
to the pth power.
Up here, p was 2.
And you take the pth root.
So maybe I should
write it to the 1/p.
Then that way, taking
pth powers and pth
roots, we do get the
norm of 2v has a factor
2 compared to the norm of v.
So p equal to 2, you see it.
We've got it right there.
p equal 1, you see it
here because it's just
the sum of the absolute values.
p equal to infinity,
if I move p up
and up and up, it
will pick out--
as I increase p,
whichever one is biggest
is going to just
take over, and that's
why you get the max norm.
Now the zero norm, where I'm
using that word improperly,
as you'll see.
So what is the zero norm?
So let me write it
[INAUDIBLE] It's
the number of
non-zero components.
It's the thing that
you'd like to know
about in question of sparsity.
Is there just one
non-zero component?
Are there 11?
Are there 101?
That you might want to minimize
that because sparse vectors
and sparse matrices are
much faster to compute with.
You've got good stuff.
But now I claim that's
not a norm, the number
of non-zero components,
because how does the norm of 2v
compare with the norm
of v, the zero norm?
It would be the same.
2v has the same number
of non-zeros as v.
So it violates the
rule for a norm.
So I think with these norms
and all the p's in between--
so actually, the math
papers are full of,
let p be between 1 and
infinity, because that's
the range where you do have a
proper norm, as we will see.
I think the good thing
to do with these norms is
to have a picture in your mind.
The geometry of a norm is good.
So the picture I'm
going to suggest
is, plot all the
vectors, let's say in 2D.
So two-dimensional space, R2.
So I want to plot the
vectors that have v equal 1
in these different norms.
So let me ask you--
so here's 2D space,
R2, and now I
want to plot all the vectors
that their ordinary l2 lengths
equal 1.
So what does that
picture look like?
I just think a picture is
really worth something.
It's a circle, thanks.
It's a circle.
This circle has the
equation, of course,
v1 squared plus v2
squared equal 1.
So I would call that the
unit ball for the norm
or whatever is a circle.
OK, now here comes
more interesting.
What about in the l1, though?
So again, tell me how to
plot all the points that
have v1 plus v2 equal 1.
What's the boundary
going to look like now?
It's going to be, let's see.
Well I can put down a
certain number of points.
There up at 1 and there at 1
and there at minus 1 and there
at minus 1.
That would reflect the
vector 1, 0 and this
would reflect the
vector 0, minus 1.
So yeah.
OK.
So those are like four
points easy to plot.
Easy to see the l1 norm.
But what's the rest
of the boundary here?
It's a diamond, good.
It's a diamond.
We have linear set equal to 1.
Up here in the
positive quadrant,
it's just v1 plus v2 equal
to 1, and the graph of that
is a straight line.
So all these guys--
this is all the points
with v1 plus v2 equal 1.
And over here and over
here and over here.
So the unit ball in the
l1 norm is a diamond.
And that's a very
important picture.
It reflects in a very
simple way something
important about the
l1 norm and the reason
it's just exploded
in importance.
Let me continue, though.
What about the max norm?
v max or v infinity equal to 1.
So again, let me
plot these guys,
and these guys are certainly
going to be in it again
because 0 [INAUDIBLE] plus or
minus i and plus or minus j
are good friends.
What's the rest of the
boundary look like now?
Now this means max of
the v's equal to 1.
So what are the
rest of the points?
You see, it does take a little
thought, but then you get it
and you don't forget it.
OK, so what's up?
I'm looking.
So suppose the maximum is v1.
I think it's going to look like
that, out to 1, 0 and up to 0,
1.
And up here, the vector
would be 1.4 or something,
so the maximum would be 1.
Is that OK?
So somehow, what really sees,
as you change this number p,
you start with p equal
to 1, or a diamond,
and it kind of swells out to
be a circle at p equal to 2,
and then it kind
of keeps swelling
to be a square and
p equal to infinity.
That's an interesting thing.
And yeah.
Now what's the problem
with the zero norm?
This is the number of non-zeros.
OK, let me draw it.
Where are the points
with one non-zero?
So I'm plotting the unit ball.
Where are the vectors in this
thing that have one non-zero?
Not zero non-zero.
So that's not included.
So what do I have?
I'm not allowed
the vector 1/3, 2/3
because that has two
non-zeros, so where
are the points with
only one non-zero?
Yeah, on the axes, yeah.
That tells you.
So it can be there and there.
Oops, without that guy.
And of course those
just keep going out.
So it totally violates the--
so maybe the point that I should
make about these figures--
so like, what's happening?
When I go down to zero--
and really, that figure should
be at the other end, right?
Oh no, shoot.
This guy's in the middle.
This is a badly drawn figure.
l2 is kind of the center guy.
l1 is at one end, l infinity
is at the other end,
and this one has gone off
the end at the left there.
The diamond has-- yeah,
what's happened here,
as that one goes down towards
zero, none of these will be OK.
These balls or these
sets will lose weight.
So they'll always
have these points in,
but they'll be like this and
then like this and then finally
in the unacceptable
limit, but none of those--
this was not any good either.
This was for people
equal 1/2, let's say.
That's a p equal to 1/2
and that's not a good norm.
Yeah.
So maybe the property of
the circle, the diamond,
and the square, which is a nice
math property of those three
sets and is not
possessed by this.
As this thing loses weight,
I lose the property.
And then of course it's
totally lost over there.
Do you know what that
property would be?
It's what?
Concave, convex.
Convex, I would say.
Convex.
This is a true norm
as the convex unit.
Well maybe for ball, I'm taking
all the v's less or equal to 1.
Yeah, so I'm allowing the
insides of these shapes.
So this is not a convex set.
That set, which I should maybe--
so not convex would
be this one like so.
And that reflects the fact
that the rules for a norm
are broken in the triangle.
Inequality is probably
broken in the--
other stuff, yeah.
I think that's sort
of worth remembering.
And then one more norm that's
natural to think about is--
so S, as in the
Piazza question, S
does always represent a
symmetric matrix in 18.065.
And now my norm is going to be--
so I'm going to
call it the S norm.
So actually, it's a positive
definite symmetric matrix.
S is a positive definite
symmetric matrix.
And what do I do?
I'll take v transpose Sv.
OK, what's our word for that?
The energy.
That's the energy in
the vector v. And I'll
take the square root so that
I now have the length of two
if I double v, from v to 2v.
Then I got a 2
here and a 2 here,
and when I take the square
root, I get a overall 2
and that's what I want.
I want the norm to grow
linearly with the two or three
or whatever I multiply by.
But what is the
shape of this thing?
So what is the shape of--
let me put it on this board.
I'm going to get a
picture like that.
So what is the shape of v
transpose Sv equal 1 or less
or equal 1?
This is a symmetric
positive definite.
People use those three
letters to tell us.
I'm claiming that we
get a bunch of norms.
When do we get the l2 norm?
What matrix S would this
give us the l2 norm?
The identity, certainly.
Now what's going to happen if
I use some different matrix S?
This circle is going
to change shape.
I might have a different
norm, depending on S.
And a typical case would
be S equal 2, 3, say.
That's a positive
definite symmetric matrix.
And now I would be drawing the
graph of 2v1 squared plus 3v2
squared.
That would be the energy, right?
Equal 1.
And I just want you to
tell me what shape that is.
So that's a perfectly
good norm that you
could check all its properties.
They all come out easily.
But I get a new picture--
a new norm that's
kind of adjustable.
You could say it's
a weighted norm.
Weights mean that
you kind of have
picked some numbers
sort of appropriate
to the particular problem.
Well, suppose those
numbers are 2 and 3.
What shape is the unit
ball in this S norm?
It's an ellipse, right.
It's an ellipse.
And I guess it
will actually be--
so the larger
number, 3, will mean
you can't go as far as
the smaller number, 2.
I think it would probably
be an ellipse like this,
and the axes length
of the ellipse
would probably have something
to do with the 2 and the 3.
OK, so now you know really
all the vector norms that
are sort of naturally used.
These come up in a natural way.
As we said, the identity matrix
brings us back to the two norm.
So these are all sort of
variations on the two norm.
And these are variations
as p runs from 1 up to 2
on to infinity and is not
allowed to go below 1.
OK, that's norms.
And then maybe you can actually
see from this picture--
here is a, like,
somewhat hokey idea
of why it is that minimizing
the area in this norm--
so what do I mean by that?
Here would be a typical problem.
Minimize, subject to
Ax equal b, the l2--
sorry, I'm using x now--
the l1 norm of x.
So that would be an
important problem.
Actually, it has a name.
People have spent a lot of
time thinking of a fast way
to solve it.
It's almost like least squares.
What would make it more
like least squares would be,
change that to 2.
Yeah.
Can I just sort of sketch,
without making a big argument
here, the difference
between l equal 1 or 2 here.
Yeah, I'll just draw a picture.
Now I'll erase this ellipse,
but you won't forget.
OK.
So this is our problem.
With l1, it has a famous
name, basis pursuit.
Well famous to people
who work in optimization.
For l2, it has an
important name.
Well it's sort of
like least squares.
Ridge regression.
This is like a
beautiful model problem.
Among all solutions
to Ax, suppose
this is just one
equation, like c1x1 plus
c2x2 equals some right side, b.
So the constraint says that the
vectors x have to be on a line.
Suppose that's a
graph of that line.
So among all these
x's, which one--
oh, I'm realizing what I'm going
to say is going to be smart.
I mean, it's going to be nice.
Not going to be difficult. Let's
do the one we know best, l2.
So here's a picture of the line.
Let me make it a little
more tilted so you--
yeah, like 2, 3.
OK.
This is the xy plane.
Here's x1, here's x2.
Here are the points that
satisfy my condition.
Which point on that
line minimizes--
has the smallest l2 norm?
Which point on the line
Yeah, you're drawing the
right figure with your hands.
The smallest l2 norm--
l2, remember, is just
how far out you go.
It's circular here, so it
doesn't matter what direction.
They're all giving the same
l2 norm, it's just how far.
So we're looking for the
closest point on the line
because we don't want
to go any further.
We want to go a
minimum distance with--
I'm doing l2 now.
So where is the point
at minimum distance?
Yeah, just show me again once
more, with hands or whatever.
It'll be that.
I didn't want 45
degree angles there.
I'm going to erase
it again and really--
this time, I'm
going to get angles
that are not 45 [INAUDIBLE]
All right, brilliant.
Got it.
OK, that's my line.
OK, and what's the nearest
point in the l2 norm?
Here's the winner in l2, right?
The nearest point.
Everybody sees that picture?
So that's a basic picture
for minimizing something
with a constraint, which
is the fundamental problem
of optimization, of neural
nets, of everything, really.
Of life.
Well I'm getting philosophical.
But the question always is,
and maybe it's true in life,
too, which norm are you using?
OK, now that was
the minimum in l2.
That's the shortest
distance, where
distance means what we usually
think of it as meaning.
But now, let's go
for the l1 norm.
Which point on the line
has the smallest l1 norm?
So now I'm going to add the 2.
So if this is some
point a, 0 and this
is some point 0, b right there.
So those two points are
obviously important.
And that point, we
could figure out
the formula for because we
know what the geometry is.
But I've just put
those two points in.
So did I get a 0, b?
Yeah, that's a zero.
So let me just ask
you the question.
What point on that line
has the smallest l1 norm?
Which has the smallest l1 norm?
Somebody said it.
Just say it a little louder so
that you're on tape forever.
AUDIENCE: 0, b.
GILBERT STRANG:
0, b, this point.
That's the winner.
This is the l1 winner and
this was the l2 winner.
And notice what I said earlier,
and I didn't see it coming,
but now I realize this is a
figure to put in the notes.
The winner has the most zeros.
It's the [? sparsest ?] vector.
Well out of two components,
it didn't have much freedom,
but it has a zero component.
It's on the axes.
It's the things on the
axes that have the smallest
number of components.
So yeah, this is the
picture in two dimensions.
So I'm in 2D.
And you can see that the winner
has a zero component, yeah.
And that's a fact that extends
into higher dimensions too
and that makes the l1 norm
special, as I've said.
Yeah.
Is there more to say
about that example?
For a simple 2D question,
that really makes the point
that the l1 winner is there.
It's not further.
You don't go further
up the line, right?
Because that's bad in all ways.
When you go up
further, you're adding
some non-zero first
component and you're
increasing the non-zero
second component,
so that's a bad idea.
That's a bad idea.
This is the winner.
And in a way,
here's the picture.
Oh yeah.
I should prepare these
lectures, but this one's
coming out all right anyway.
So the picture there is
the nearest ball hits
at that point.
And what is it?
Can you see that?
So that star is
outside the circle.
This is the l1 winner and
that's the blow up the l1 norm
until it hits.
That's the point where
the l1 norm hits.
Do you see it?
Just give it a little thought,
that another geometric way
to see the answer
to this problem is,
you start at the
origin and you blow up
the norm until you get
a point on the line that
satisfies your constraint.
And because you were blowing up
the norm, when it hits first,
that's the smallest
blow-up possible.
That's the guy that minimizes.
Yeah, so just think
about that picture
and I'll draw it
better somewhere, too.
Well that's vector norms.
And then I introduce some
matrix norms, and let me just
say a word about those.
OK, a word about matrix norms.
So the matrix norms were the--
so now I have a matrix A and I
want to define those same three
norms again for a matrix.
And this was the
2 norm, and what
was the 2 norm of a matrix?
Well it was sigma 1,
it turned out to be.
So that doesn't define it.
Or we could define it.
Just say, OK, the
largest singular value
is the 2 norm of the matrix.
But actually, it
comes from somewhere.
So I want to speak about
this one first, the 2 norm.
So it's the 2 norm of
a matrix, and one way
to see the 2 norm of a
matrix is to connect it
to the 2 norm of vectors.
I'd like to connect
the 2 norm of matrices
to the 2 norm of vectors.
And how shall I do that?
I think I'm going to
look at the 2 norm of Ax
over the 2 norm of x.
So in a way, to me, that ratio
is like the blow-up factor.
If A was seven
times the identity,
to take an easy case--
if A is seven
times the identity,
what will that ratio be?
Say it, yeah.
Seven.
If A is 7i, this will be 7x
and this will be x, and norms,
the factor seven comes out,
so that ratio will be seven.
OK.
For me, the norm is--
that's the blow-up factor.
So here's the idea
of a matrix norm.
Now I'm doing matrix.
Matrix norm from vector norm.
And the answer will be
the maximum blow-up.
The maximum of this ratio.
I call that ratio
the blow-up factor.
That's just a made-up name.
The maximum over all x.
All of x.
I look to see which vector
gets blown up the most
and that is the
norm of the matrix.
I've settled on
norms of vectors.
That's done upstairs there.
Now I'm looking at
norms of matrices.
And this is one way to get
a good norm of a matrix that
kind of comes from the 2 norm.
So there would be other
norms for matrices coming
from other vector norms,
and those, we haven't seen,
but the 2 norm is a
very important one.
So what is the
maximum value of this?
Of that ratio for a matrix A?
The claim is that it's sigma 1.
I'll just put a
big equality there.
Now, can we see, why is sigma
1 the answer to this problem?
I can see a couple of
ways to think about that
but that's a very
important fact.
In fact, this is a way to
discover what sigma 1 is
without all the other sigmas.
If I look for the x that has
the biggest blow-up factor--
and by the way,
which x will it be?
Which x will win the max
competition here and be sigma
1 times as large as--
the ratio will be sigma 1.
That will be sigma 1.
When is this thing sigma
1 times as large as that?
For which x?
Not for an eigenvector.
If x was an eigenvector,
what would that ratio be?
Lambda.
But if A is not a
symmetric matrix,
maybe the eigenvectors don't
tell you the exact way they go.
So what vector
would you now guess?
It's not an eigenvector,
it is a singular vector.
And which singular vector
is it probably going to be?
v1.
Yeah, v1 makes sense.
Winner.
So the winner of
this competition
is x equal v1, the first
right singular vector.
And we better be
able to check that.
So again, this maximization
problem, the answer
is in terms of the
singular vector.
So that's a way to find
this first singular vector
without finding them all.
And let's just plug in
the first singular vector
and see that the
ratio is sigma 1.
So now let me plug it in.
So what do I have?
I want Av1 over length of v1.
OK.
And I'm hoping to
get that answer.
Well what's the
denominator here?
The length of v1 is one.
So no big deal there.
That's one.
What's the length
of the top one?
Now what is Av1?
If v1 is the first right
singular vector, than Av1
is sigma 1 times u1.
Remember, the singular vector
deals were Av equals sigma u.
Avk equals sigma k uk.
You remember that.
So they're not eigenvectors.
They're singular vectors.
So Av1 is the length of sigma
1 u1 and it's divided by 1.
And of course, u1 is also a unit
vector, so I just get sigma 1.
OK.
So that's another
way to say that you
can find sigma 1 by solving
this maximum problem.
And you get that sigma 1.
OK.
And I could get
other matrix norms
by maximizing that blow-up
factor in that vector norm.
I won't do that now, just to
keep control of what we've got.
Now what was the next matrix
norm that came in last time?
Very, very important one for
deep learning and neural nets.
Somehow it's a little
simpler than this guy.
And what was that matrix norm?
What letter whose
name goes here?
Frobenius.
So capital F for Frobenius.
And what was that?
That was the square root
of the sum of all the--
add all the aij squares,
for all over the matrix,
and then take the square root.
And then somebody asked a
good question after class
on Wednesday, what has that
got to do with the sigmas?
Because my point was that
these norms are the guys that
go with the sigmas, that have
nice formulas for the sigmas,
and here it is.
It's the square root of the
sum of the squares of all
the sigmas.
So let me write Frobenius again.
But this notation with an
F is now pretty standard,
and we should be able to
see why that number is
the same as that number.
Yeah.
I could give you a
reason or I could put it
on the problem set.
Yeah, I think that's
better on the problem
set, because first of
all, I get off the hook
right away, and secondly,
this connection between--
in Frobenius, that's a beautiful
fact about Frobenius norm
that you add up all
the sigma squares--
it's just m times n of them
because it's a filled matrix.
So another way to say it
is, we haven't written down
the SVD today, A equal
u sigma v transposed.
And the point is that,
for the Frobenius norm--
actually, for all these norms--
I can change u.
It doesn't change the norm,
so I can make u the identity.
u, as we all know, is
an orthogonal matrix,
and what I'm saying
is, orthogonal matrix u
doesn't change any of
these particular norms.
So suppose it was the identity.
Same here.
That could be the identity
without changing the norm.
So we're down to the
norm of Frobenius.
So what's the Frobenius
norm of that guy?
What's the Frobenius norm
of that diagonal matrix?
Well you're supposed
to add up the squares
of all the numbers in the
matrix and what do you get?
You get that, right?
So that's why this
is the same as this
because the orthogonal guy there
and the orthogonal guy there
make no difference in the norm.
But that takes checking, right?
Yeah.
But that's another
way to see why
the Frobenius norm gives this.
And then finally, this
was the nuclear norm.
And actually, just
before my lunch
lecture on the subject
of probability--
I've had a learning morning.
The lunch lecture was about this
crazy way that humans behave.
Not us but other humans.
Other actual-- well, no,
I don't want to say that.
Take that out of the tape.
Yeah, OK.
Anyway, that was that
lecture, but before that
was a lecture for an hour plus
about deep learning by somebody
who really, really has
begun to understand
what is happening inside.
How does that gradient
descent optimization
algorithm pick out, what
does it pick out as the thing
it learns.
This is going to be our
goal in this course.
We're not there yet.
But his conjecture is that--
yeah, so it's a conjecture.
He doesn't have a proof.
He's got proofs
of some nice cases
where things commute but he
hasn't got the whole thing yet,
but it's pretty terrific work.
So this was Professor
Srebro who's in Chicago.
So he just announced
his conjecture,
and his conjecture is that, in a
modeled case, the deep learning
that we'll learn about
with the gradient descent
that we'll learn about to
find the best weights--
the point is that, in
a typical deep learning
problem these days, there are
many more weights than samples
and so there are a lot
of possible minima.
Many different weights
give the same minimum loss
because there are
so many weights.
The problem is, like,
got too many variables,
but it turns out to be
a very, very good thing.
That's part of the success.
And he believes that
in a model situation,
that optimization
by gradient descent
picks out the weights that
minimize the nuclear norm.
So this would be a norm
of a lot of weights.
And he thinks that's
where the system goes.
We'll see this.
This comes up in
compressed sensing,
as I mentioned last time.
But now I have to remember
what was the definition.
Do you remember what
the nuclear norm?
He often used a little
star instead of an N.
I'll put that in the notes.
Other people call
it the trace norm.
But I think this N kind of gives
it a notation you can remember.
So let's call it
the nuclear norm.
Do you remember
what that one was?
Yeah, somebody's
saying it right.
Add the sigmas, yeah.
Just the sum of the sigmas,
like the l1 norm, in a way.
So that's the idea,
is that this is
the natural sort of l1
type of norm for matrices.
It's the l1 norm for
that sigma vector.
This would be the l2
norm of the sigma vector.
That would be the
l infinity norm.
Notice that the vector numbers,
infinity, 2, and 1, get
changed around when you
look at the matrix guy.
So that's an exciting idea
and it remains to be proved.
And expert people are
experimenting to see,
is it true?
Yeah.
So that's a big thing
for their future.
Yes.
OK, so today, we've
talked about norms
and this section of the notes
will be all about norms.
We've taken a big leap into
a comment about deep learning
and this is what I
want to say the most.
And I say it to
every class I teach
near the start of the semester.
My feeling about what my
job is to teach you things,
or to join with you in learning
things, as happened today.
It's not to grade you.
I don't spend any time
losing sleep-- you know,
should that person take a
one point or epsilon penalty
for turning it in
four minutes late?
To Hell with that, right?
We've got a lot to do here.
So anyway, we'll
get on with the job.
So homework three
coming up, and you'll
be using the notes
that you already
have posted in Stellar for
those sections eight and nine
and so on.
And we'll keep going on Monday.
OK, see you on Monday
and have a great weekend.